I think the most important thing that I
have learned is that there's more to
learn that we should that we that we
should all be hungry for a lifetime I
mean for example had my next birthday
I'll be 68 and all the great scientific
discoveries made by all the great
geniuses were largely made when they
were in their 20s and 30s
and yet I became about two years ago
obsessed with particle physics and I was
determined to understand it before I
died I could not have done that if I
hadn't learned to read when I was young
if I hadn't had the opportunity to study
science courses in my high school and I
lived in the second poorest state in the
United States which most people my age
and my state did not have I happened to
go to a bigger high school with people
who understood we had to get good
science and math teachers there and if I
hadn't gone to in my case Georgetown
University which was a Jesuit University
and I hadn't been subject to the kind of
rigors that the Jesuits impose which
made me realize that however much I
thought I knew and however smart I was I
didn't know very much and I wasn't very
smart I had a lot to learn so that's the
most important thing I learned that your
brain is a gift and we now know that
people well into their late 60s and 70s
can form new neural networks so that
even though your brain begins to shrink
in your 30s
and does throughout your life since none
of us ever use even close to half of our
brainpower we got a lot left and we will
in our land on our last day on earth
we'll have a lot left so the idea that
we now know as a scientific measure
because of all the brain scanning
technology that we can form these
networks and that we form them best
we're most likely to form new neural
networks later in life by learning
something new so if I said I was
interested in particle physics and also
in astrophysics and I'm trying to figure
out what it means that we've located 20
planets outside our solar system in the
last five years that seemed to have
enough density and be far enough away
from their Suns that they might be able
to support life that may be the answer
to the rusty Ukraine problem an attack
from out an attack from outer space will
immediately unite us all members of
Congress in the US will immediately
start hugging each other and singing
Kumbaya but anyway I can form new neural
networks doing that because I don't know
anything about it or I didn't when I
started a theoretical physicist would do
better going to Suzuki piano lessons
with his grandchild or her grandchild
and just playing if you knew nothing
about music but this is an incredible
thing that the most important thing I
learned is that it's important to keep
on learning that you should stay hungry
and that the greatest gift can be even
as your body begins to fail if your
minds still working you need to use it
[Applause]
you